this is juba  an eastern black rhino  coming in at around  2690 pounds big is an understatement  but with less than 740 left in the wild  the eastern black rhino is one of the  rarest rhinos in the world  juba is 20 years old and stands close to  12 feet long  they are solitary animals with an  aggressive disposition to discourage  predators  they may seem tranquil but they will  charge first and investigate later  black rhinos are browsers and eat leafy  plants branches shoots and whatever else  they can find in the highland and  savannah habitats  his large ears can rotate to pick up  sounds from many directions  today eastern black rhinos are only left  in kenya and tanzania  the population has declined by 90  percent over the last three generations  the biggest threat for these guys are  humans as poaching has absolutely  devastated their population  this is the eastern black rhino